finally tonight a message from Brett and
his family thanking you for sticking
with us all these years and of course
wishing you all a very Merry Christmas
everybody Merry Christmas and Happy New
Year from my family to yours we wish you
the best of holiday season believe it or
not we've been doing this for almost ten
years some of the video is pretty funny
we have a lot of things to be thankful
for a Merry Christmas and a Happy New
Year's we are excited for the holidays
very excited for Christmas and we're
going to get through it how all together
that was a good one so as you can see
the family has changed over the years a
bit and what are you doing Amy wishing
you a very Merry Christmas from our
family to yours and a blessed
20:19 wishing you a holly jolly
Christmas and a Happy New Year wishing
you a very Merry Christmas and a Happy
New Year one year older and one year
wiser
there you go wiser and we want to do it
fair balanced and do you guys want to
you want to sing your way out
[Music]
okay little singing Merry Christmas to
the Bears and merry Christmas to all of
you